foreign
[Music]
here raised here
this Dome is the only World you've ever
known
as a place just off past the Eastern
Ridge
right there dad what are you talking
about you'll see
get out there
whatever's out there your dad wants you
to see him we've never even been outside
the Dome before
so what's it gonna be we're leaving
tonight I hear it's weird why
is Earth so the peculiar you're peculiar
all in favor
let's go steal her over
three two one
you know the best thing about road trips
everything behind
here it is bottom of the knife the wind
up
foreign
[Music]
isn't really blue yeah
the important thing to remember this is
a bad idea
[Music]
it's just about where you're going
to your shower
run it's about how you get there
the people you get there with Caleb
what's in the crater I don't know
guess we'll find out you guys go first
you know quite the same as you were when
you began
days of my life
[Music]